其他人：酸奶要吗
Others: Do you want yogurt?
其他人：买两对可以送你一排
Others: Buy two pairs and get a whole row for free.
Katrina:  买两对可以送我一排
Katrina: Buy two pairs and get a whole row for free?
Katrina:  这保质期几天
Katrina: What's the shelf life?
其他人：保质期是都是好日期的25天保质期
Others: The shelf life is 25 days, all with good dates.
Katrina:  那我买两排再送一个什么嘞
Katrina: If I buy two rows, what do I get?
其他人：送你不是这买
Others: If you buy...
其他人：买等于是买两对吗
Others: It's like buying two pairs.
其他人： 送三杯
Others: You get three cups.
其他人：眼睛怎么是亮的呀
Others: Why are your glasses glowing?
Katrina:  啊因为我们在充电这个东西
Katrina: Oh, because we're charging them.
其他人：眼镜还要充电啊
Others: Your glasses need charging?
Katrina:  对因为这个眼睛有那个摄像头功能
Katrina: Yeah, because they have a camera function.
Katrina:  哎那就是我买这个是19块9是吧
Katrina: So, this one is 19.9, right?
其他人：啊
Others: Yeah.
Alice:你能喝纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you drink plain yogurt?
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Yes, I can.
其他人：啊你们都带着摄像头呢
Others: Oh, you all have cameras?
Alice:就是你吃过纯酸奶
Alice: Have you ever had plain yogurt?
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Alice:这个一点糖都没了
Alice: There's no sugar left at all.
Katrina:  行我都行
Katrina: Okay, I'm fine with it.
Katrina:  可以试试嘛
Katrina: We can try it, right?
Katrina:  那我们拿个这个
Katrina: Let's take this one then.
Lucia:  会比会比普通这种酸奶要酸一些
Lucia: It's going to be a bit more sour than regular yogurt.
Alice:没事你你可以买你的普通酸奶
Alice: It's okay, you can buy your regular yogurt.
Alice:因为我这个可能就两三个人
Alice: Because only two or three people might...
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Alice:你可以买普通的
Alice: You can buy the regular one.
Jake: 豆汁
Jake: Fermented bean juice.
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ah hahaha.
Tasha:  没有我只是看到了
Tasha: No, I just saw it.
Katrina:  你你喝过豆汁没
Katrina: Have you ever tried fermented bean juice?
Jake: 我喝过啊
Jake: Yeah, I've tried it.
Lucia:  啊我没喝过啊
Lucia: Ah, I haven't tried it.
Jake: 哪哪一款
Jake: Which one?
Jake: 哈哈哈多少钱啊
Jake: Haha, how much is it?
Katrina:  啊哈哈
Katrina: Ah haha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia:  怎么如此热情哈哈
Lucia: Why so enthusiastic? Haha.
其他人：八块八
Others: Eight dollars and eighty cents.
Shure:  看杨老板累的
Shure: Look, Jake is tired.
Katrina:  杨老板要喝豆汁
Katrina: Jake wants to drink fermented bean juice.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  好生蚝
Katrina: Good oysters.
Jake: 行行行真的真的
Jake: Sure, sure, really, really.
Shure:  补补这3新币
Shure: Make up for this three Singapore dollars.
Jake: 补补补补
Jake: Make up, make up.
Jake: 我去
Jake: I'm going.
Jake: 一个10块钱够了啊
Jake: Ten dollars should be enough.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice:这一共三新币
Alice: This is a total of three Singapore dollars.
Shure:  一共3新币啊
Shure: It's a total of three Singapore dollars?
Jake: 我知道就是大概一个10新币
Jake: I know, it's about ten Singapore dollars.
Alice:一个10新币
Alice: Ten Singapore dollars each.
Shure:  就是在在在新加坡的
Shure: That's in, in, in Singapore.
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Really?
Jake: 对在我在我家门口的那个商场里边
Jake: Yes, at the mall near my home.
Lucia:  为什么
Lucia: Why?
Lucia:  你们不是靠海吗
Lucia: Aren't you by the sea?
Lucia:  怎么还这么贵
Lucia: Why is it still so expensive?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 他就是这个价啊
Jake: That's just the price.
Katrina:  新加坡物价这么贵
Katrina: Prices in Singapore are this high?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jake: 一个10新币
Jake: One for 10 SGD.
Shure:  快给杨老板补补
Shure: Quick, someone give Jake a boost.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  3新币咱可劲吃
Shure: We could eat a lot for 3 SGD.
Jake: 这多少个
Jake: How many is that?
Katrina:  是多少呢
Katrina: How many exactly?
Lucia:  所有的三新币吗
Lucia: All for 3 SGD?
Jake: 这几个呀几个呀一二
Jake: How many are there, one, two...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure:  10个左右大概
Shure: Around 10, I guess.
Jake: 10个100新币
Jake: 10 for 100 SGD.
Shure:  10个 100新币
Shure: 10 for 100 SGD.
Jake: 500块钱你花了3
Jake: You spent 500 RMB, and you only spent 3 SGD.
Jake: 你花了3新币
Jake: You spent 3 SGD.
Shure:  3新币
Shure: 3 SGD.
Lucia:  一共三新币
Lucia: Only 3 SGD in total.
Shure:  一共3新币
Shure: Only 3 SGD in total.
Shure:  19块9啊 18块9是吧
Shure: 19.9 RMB, or 18.9 RMB, right?
Alice:晚上就要拆开这个
Alice: We have to open this tonight.
Shure:  3新币差不多
Shure: About 3 SGD.
Jake: 是是是你这大
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you got this big one.
Alice:晚上就要拆开
Alice: We have to open it tonight.
Lucia:  可呀我们可以那个啥
Lucia: But we can, you know...
Lucia:  就是晚吃
Lucia: Eat it later.
Jake: 中国我当500多了
Jake: In China, it would be over 500 RMB.
Lucia:  晚饭的时候吃它刚好可以解腻
Lucia: Eating it for dinner would be just right to cut the grease.
Jake: 哈哈哈虚报虚报
Jake: Haha, exaggerated price.
Alice:回去我就想吃这个
Alice: I really want to eat this when we get back.
Tasha:  pick me
Tasha: Pick me.
Lucia:  哇塞那这真的好好好划算啊
Lucia: Wow, that’s really a good deal.
Jake: 这个还是能感觉出来的
Jake: You can still feel it.
Katrina:  面包在哪来着
Katrina: Where did the bread come from?
Jake: 呵呵这in w的这个
Jake: Hehe, this is from in w.
Katrina:  面包番茄酱
Katrina: Bread and ketchup.
Katrina:  姐你们面包也可以加酸奶是不是
Katrina: Sis, you can add yogurt to your bread, right?
Alice:番茄酱
Alice: Ketchup.
Alice:吃不惯面包
Alice: I can't get used to bread.
Katrina:  在这面包是吗
Katrina: Is this bread?
Alice:你去选你想要的
Alice: You go pick what you want.
Katrina:  我就买那普通的切片面包就行
Katrina: I'll just get the regular sliced bread.
Katrina:  明天早饭是自己弄是吧
Katrina: We're making our own breakfast tomorrow, right?
Shure:  鲜软
Shure: Soft and fresh.
Katrina:  就随便拿
Katrina: Just grab whatever.
Katrina:  这种我都行
Katrina: I'm fine with any of these.
Shure:  现代吐司来吧
Shure: Let's get the modern toast.
Katrina: 搞点什么酱呢
Katrina: What kind of spread should we get?
Katrina:  搞奶酪吗
Katrina: Cheese?
Katrina:  还是搞果酱
Katrina: Or maybe jam?
Shure:  啊蒜还有啊
Shure: Ah, we still have garlic.
Shure:  咱们昨天买的那个蒜还有啊有啊
Shure: We still have the garlic we bought yesterday.
Katrina:  123我们6个人是不是拿两袋啊
Katrina: 123, there are six of us, should we get two bags?
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  没有辣的了
Shure: No more spicy ones.
Katrina:  两袋搞一点什么呢
Katrina: Two bags, what should we get?
Katrina:  番茄酱在哪
Katrina: Where's the ketchup?
Katrina:  你们刚有看见吗
Katrina: Did you guys see it?
Alice:没注意到没看到
Alice: Didn't notice, didn't see it.
Katrina:  你吃面包吗
Katrina: Do you eat bread?
Katrina:  早上那他明天早上就让自己吃哎
Katrina: Tomorrow morning, he'll have to make his own breakfast.
Alice:我不吃面包
Alice: I don't eat bread.
Katrina:  怎么办那你吃点水果那种
Katrina: What should we do then, you can have some fruit?
Alice:无所谓我早上
Alice: Whatever, in the morning...
Katrina:  不怎么吃东西啊
Katrina: You don't eat much in the morning, huh?
Katrina:  早上面包里加搞点啥呢
Katrina: What should we put in the bread in the morning?
Alice:番茄片你吃番茄吗
Alice: Tomato slices, do you eat tomatoes?
Lucia:  奶酪
Lucia: Cheese.
Katrina:  奶酪也行啊
Katrina: Cheese works too.
Alice:看英国干巴老头吗
Alice: Do you watch that British old man?
Katrina:  看又做他的干巴了
Katrina: Yeah, he's making his dry stuff again.
Alice:又做他的干巴lunch哈哈
Alice: Making his dry lunch again, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈其实他那种果酱也很好看
Katrina: Haha, actually his jam looks pretty good.
Katrina:  就是他那个切的面包邦硬你知道吗
Katrina: But the bread he cuts is super hard, you know?
Alice:梆硬然后
Alice: Super hard and...
Katrina:  他们说吃这个吗
Katrina: They said we should eat this?
Katrina:  英国人
Katrina: The British?
Alice:然后搞点那个干巴黄油
Alice: And then add some of that dry butter.
Katrina:  也可以拿
Katrina: We can take it too.
Katrina:  果酱随便哎
Katrina: Jam is free to take.
Katrina:  有了哎还有奶油哎
Katrina: Got it, and there's cream too.
Lucia:  柠檬塔味
Lucia: Lemon tart flavor.
Alice:我们家是不是也有对对
Alice: Doesn't our house have some too?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:  对对咱们房子里还有奶油
Lucia: Yeah, we still have some cream at home.
Lucia:  你是更想吃奶酪还是更想吃果酱
Lucia: Do you feel like having cheese or jam?
Katrina:  我无所谓
Katrina: I don't mind.
Katrina:  我想吃番茄酱
Katrina: I feel like having ketchup.
Alice:那我们找番茄酱吧
Alice: Then let's find some ketchup.
Lucia:  也行那我可以拿一个这个吗
Lucia: Sure, can I take one of these?
Lucia:  有人还有别人想吃吗
Lucia: Does anyone else want some?
Katrina:  拿呗
Katrina: Go ahead.
Alice:你拿了就有人吃
Alice: If you take it, someone will eat it.
Lucia:  那我拿了
Lucia: Then I'll take it.
Lucia:  夹带私货
Lucia: Sneaking in some extras.
Katrina:  我也夹带私货了
Katrina: I'm sneaking in some extras too.
Katrina:  一罐冰淇淋
Katrina: A tub of ice cream.
Katrina:  番茄酱你知道在哪吗
Katrina: Do you know where the ketchup is?
Katrina:  番茄酱就是鸡蛋饼
Katrina: Ketchup is with the egg pancakes.
其他人：番茄酱在那米面粮油
Others: Ketchup is with the grains and oils.
Katrina: 这里面好好谢谢
Katrina: In here? Thanks a lot.
Lucia:  哎帝王蟹腿
Lucia: Oh, king crab legs.
Jake: 差不多在这了是吧
Jake: Almost done here, right?
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:  对上次逛了时候还是鲜活的
Lucia: Last time we shopped, they were still alive.
Katrina:  跟帝王蟹杠上拿了番茄酱
Katrina: Now we're competing with the king crab for ketchup.
Lucia:  这次已经变成冷藏的
Lucia: Now they're refrigerated.
Katrina:  没了吧
Katrina: All gone, right?
Shure:  call back一下是吗
Shure: Need to call back, right?
Katrina:  油油拿了是吧
Katrina: Did you take the oil?
Shure:  油有家里有油
Shure: We have oil at home.
Alice:家里有
Alice: We have it at home.
Katrina:  那就OK了
Katrina: Then it's all good.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  够了
Katrina: Enough.
Shure:  车子都放不下了
Shure: There's no space left in the car.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  老板的眼神感觉
Shure: The boss's look feels...
Jake: 哈哈哈今天只有一车还行
Jake: Hahaha, today we only have one car, it's alright.
Shure:  感觉钱包又被掏空了一次是吧
Shure: Feels like my wallet got emptied again, right?
Shure:  哎哪边是结账来着
Shure: Hey, where do we pay?
Katrina: 这边
Katrina: This way.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 是不是少个人呢
Jake: Are we missing someone?
Alice:哎那呢
Alice: Hey, over there.
Jake: 哪了
Jake: Where?
Alice:那呢
Alice: Over there.
Jake: 哦呵背景太绿了我看不出来
Jake: Oh, the background is too green, I couldn't see.
Tasha:  我想把这个拿出来不要了
Tasha: I want to take this out, don't want it anymore.
Katrina: 咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Tasha:  啊没咋
Tasha: Ah, nothing.
Tasha:  因为这两个才200
Tasha: Because these two are only 200.
Tasha:  可要40块钱
Tasha: But they cost 40 bucks.
Tasha:  这个300克
Tasha: This one is 300 grams.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha:  那我还回去
Tasha: Then I'll put it back.
Jake: 您好谢谢
Jake: Hello, thank you.
Katrina:  多见我
Katrina: See you more often.
Katrina:  免费领菜区
Katrina: Free vegetable area.
Katrina:  真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure:  真的吧
Shure: Really, I guess.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Lucia:  会员免费领菜去
Lucia: Members get free vegetables.
Katrina:  那我们是会员不
Katrina: Are we members?
Katrina:  我们买这么多东西了
Katrina: We bought so much stuff.
Katrina:  可以送我们一袋金针菇吗呵
Katrina: Can you give us a bag of enoki mushrooms?
Shure:  3个袋吧先咱
Shure: How about three bags first?
Katrina:  行
Katrina: Deal.
Shure:  来吧开始吧
Shure: Alright, let's start.
Lucia:  我再去拿个车过来
Lucia: I'll go get another cart.
Lucia:  然后我们扫完的可以放另一个车里
Lucia: Then we can put the scanned items in the other cart.
Shure:  会员登录
Shure: Member login.
Shure:  今天谁登关注我
Shure: Who logged in today, follow me.
Katrina:  微微
Katrina: Weiwei.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake
Alice:我也行
Alice: I can do it too
Katrina:  你也行是吧那你行
Katrina: You can do it? Okay, you do it then
Alice:看我有那个啥
Alice: Look, I have that thing
Alice:把我家地址给挡了
Alice: Block my home address
Jake: 我我我试试
Jake: I-I-I'll try
Jake: 这那个用的什么码呀
Jake: What code does this use?
Shure:  盒马APP
Shure: Hema APP
Katrina:  会员满
Katrina: Membership full
Jake: 一定要盒马是吧
Jake: It has to be Hema, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes
Alice:我有但是我
Alice: I have it, but I...
Jake: 没有啥也没有
Jake: Don't have anything
Alice:现在可以关吗
Alice: Can I turn it off now?
Jake: 呃你你我有你要一定要关吗干嘛呢
Jake: Uh, you, you, I have it, do you have to turn it off? What are you doing?
Lucia:  刷完的可以放这边
Lucia: You can put the finished ones here
Katrina:  好的
Katrina: Okay
Shure:  我们在付钱
Shure: We're paying
Jake: 那
Jake: Then
Alice:呀就把我家地址给漏了
Alice: Oh, I leaked my home address
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure
Jake: 好那请吧
Jake: Okay, go ahead
Alice:好吧
Alice: Alright
Jake: 去吧就
Jake: Go ahead then
Shure:  好吧那又靠你了
Shure: Alright, it's up to you again
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake: 但是券已经用完了是吧
Jake: But the coupon is already used up, right?
Tasha:  看看能不能买点
Tasha: See if you can buy some
Jake: 啊不用不用不用不用不用
Jake: Ah no need, no need, no need, no need
Katrina:  那你会员可以免费领吗
Katrina: Can you get it for free with your membership?
Shure:  是你的事情
Shure: That's your business
Shure:  他那个付付费会员才会有这个
Shure: Only paid membership has that
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha
Tasha:  二百九十八一年
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah
Lucia:  我刚刚点开看了一下
Lucia: I just clicked and checked
Katrina:  要3个是不是
Katrina: So we need three, right?
Lucia:  我好像又掉线了
Lucia: I think I got disconnected again.
Lucia:  就在你说完之后
Lucia: Right after you finished talking.
Jake: 哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia:  我说我去检查一下
Lucia: I said I would check it out.
Jake: 你只要是亮着的就没关系
Jake: As long as the light is on, it's fine.
Lucia:  哦那就行
Lucia: Oh, that's good then.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  这纯靠自觉呗
Katrina: So we rely on self-discipline, huh?
Katrina:  我多拽几个他也不知道啊
Katrina: I could grab a few more, and he wouldn’t know.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yep.
Tasha:  看看能不能买个这个
Tasha: Let’s see if we can buy this.
Shure:  你试试吧
Shure: You give it a try.
Katrina:  对那个了吗
Katrina: Is it that one?
Katrina:  放那个筐里到时候我们弄完了就往那边移
Katrina: Put it in the basket, and when we’re done, we’ll move it over there.
Shure:  码在哪呢
Shure: Where’s the code?
Shure:  这先先等一会
Shure: Let’s wait a bit.
Shure:  问问工作人员吧
Shure: Ask the staff.
Alice:肉放一块吧
Alice: Put the meat together.
Katrina:  然后把它往那个筐里移
Katrina: Then move it to that basket.
Katrina:  流水线工作
Katrina: Assembly line work.
Katrina: 这是什么价啊
Katrina: What's the price for this?
Lucia:  重一点的也可以分开放
Lucia: Heavier ones can be separated.
Lucia:  那个料酒
Lucia: That cooking wine.
Lucia:  要不然放这袋子里
Lucia: Or put it in this bag.
Alice:把肉啥的搁过来吧
Alice: Bring the meat over here.
Alice:或者是冷冻的菜也先不搁
Alice: Or we can leave the frozen veggies out for now.
Alice:肉肉成盒的搁这
Alice: Put the packaged meat here.
Shure:  我快转晕了
Shure: I’m getting dizzy from turning.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:还有肉没
Alice: Any more meat?
Alice:把那几个肉解开搁这里面吧
Alice: Untie those meats and put them here.
Lucia:  放不下的话就放这袋子里
Lucia: If they don’t fit, put them in this bag.
Jake:袋子哪领的呀
Jake: Where did you get the bags?
Lucia:  呃呃那边
Lucia: Umm, over there.
Alice:买的
Alice: Bought them.
Katrina:  哎还有一盒肉
Katrina: Oh, there’s another box of meat.
Shure:  3个袋 4个袋子一新币差不多
Shure: Three bags, four bags, about one dollar.
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: That expensive?
Lucia:  这袋子这么贵哇
Lucia: These bags are so expensive!
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Jake: 一新币啊
Jake: One Singapore dollar?
Tasha:  可降解
Tasha: Biodegradable
Lucia:  现在国内的袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Now bags are this expensive in our country too.
Shure:  在国内的啊
Shure: In our country?
Jake: 这一块多钱
Jake: How much is this one?
Alice:并且他现在你外送的话必须买袋子
Alice: And now if you want delivery, you must buy a bag.
Jake: 这一块多钱一个袋子是吗我去
Jake: Over one dollar for a bag? Oh my!
Shure:  一块5一个
Shure: One dollar fifty each.
Shure:  哎又给你换到6了哈哈哈
Shure: Hey, it changed to six again, haha.
Lucia:  哎不过其实到哈哈哈
Lucia: But actually, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:  不过其实到处袋子都收钱
Lucia: But actually, you pay for bags everywhere.
Lucia:  不过我没想到
Lucia: I just didn't expect it.
Lucia:  国内现在袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Now bags are this expensive in our country too.
Katrina:  没了这也没弄是不是
Katrina: It's gone, isn't it?
Shure:  这个弄了吧
Shure: This one is done, right?
Shure:  就只有这个没动了是吧
Shure: Only this one left, right?
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello
Lucia:  哦
Lucia: Oh
Shure:  我们找找
Shure: Let's look for it
Shure:  他码呢
Shure: Where's the code?
Shure:  他码没了
Shure: The code is gone.
Shure:  是这个吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Katrina: 里面啊
Katrina: It's inside.
Tasha:  开打之后打8.8折
Tasha: After opening, there's an 8.8 discount.
Katrina:  后面反面
Katrina: On the back.
Jake: 好吧那应该开什么还是什么呀
Jake: Okay, so what should we open?
Katrina:  反面是条形嘛
Katrina: The barcode is on the back.
Tasha:  应该第一天就开
Tasha: Should have opened on the first day.
Shure:  OK搞定
Shure: Okay, done.
Jake: 卡多少钱
Jake: How much is the card?
Lucia:  这个会这个外面会有水蒸气的话
Lucia: If there will be condensation outside.
Lucia:  要不然跟这个放一块
Lucia: Otherwise, put it together with this.
Tasha:  258 好吧
Tasha: 258, okay?
Lucia:  因为面包袋子是纸
Lucia: Because the bread bag is paper.
Shure:  好来来来
Shure: Okay, come on.
Tasha:  付钱了吗已经
Tasha: Have you paid already?
Shure:  大小姐
Shure: Miss
Shure:  对到付钱了
Shure: Yeah, it's time to pay.
Shure:  到最需要你的时候了
Shure: Now is when we really need you.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  你你是怎么给他报账的
Katrina: How do you report expenses to him?
Katrina:  每天都给他报账吗
Katrina: Do you report them every day?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  我已经几天没报了
Katrina: I haven't reported for a few days.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector.
Shure:  这个又得端着了是吗
Shure: Do I need to hold this again?
Jake: 护蛋使者
Jake: Egg protector.
Lucia:  我端着吧
Lucia: I'll hold it.
Katrina:  放放我这袋子
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Katrina:  我抱这个袋子
Katrina: I'll hold this bag.
Lucia:  咱们是不是还有个饮料没放到这里面
Lucia: Didn't we have a drink that we didn't put in here?
Katrina: 放我袋子里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Jake: 那个还有是吗
Jake: Is there still some left?
Katrina:  那披萨我也来拿
Katrina: I'll take the pizza too.
Katrina:  你们其他拿那个
Katrina: You guys take the other stuff.
Alice:那你喝的你拿着还是给你放着
Alice: Are you going to hold your drink or should I put it away for you?
Lucia:  这个能能放下吗
Lucia: Can this fit?
Lucia:  放不下我就拿着好了
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, I'll hold it.
Lucia:  雨轩那个袋子会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Yuxuan, isn't that bag a bit heavy?
Katrina:  还好啊
Katrina: It's okay.
Lucia:  你先先放这里面推着吧
Lucia: You can put it here first, push it.
Lucia:  要不要放这里啊
Lucia: Should we put them here?
Katrina:  鸡蛋要不要放这里啊
Katrina: Should we put the eggs here?
Lucia:  哦哎可以可以
Lucia: Oh, yeah, we can.
Lucia:  同志们鸡蛋可以和这个放一起对吧
Lucia: Comrades, can we put the eggs together with this?
Tasha:  先放这吧要不要
Tasha: Let's put it here first.
Alice:就先这样吧
Alice: Let's just leave it like this for now.
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:  也行可以都先放到车里
Lucia: Okay, we can put everything in the car first.
Lucia:  然后一会提的时候再拿出来
Lucia: Then we'll take them out when we need them.
Katrina:  go go go
Katrina: Go go go.
Shure:  哦没买百事可乐我靠
Shure: Oh, we forgot to buy Pepsi, damn it.
Jake: 为什么要百事可乐
Jake: Why do we need Pepsi?
Shure:  因为腌东西的那个百事会更甜一点
Shure: Because Pepsi is sweeter for marinating stuff.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  可口反正它就不好
Shure: Coke just doesn't work as well.
Jake: 好这能推到哪
Jake: Okay, how far can we push this?
Katrina:  嗯right
Katrina: Hmm, right.
Katrina:  直接打商务车是吧
Katrina: Just take the business van, right?
其他人：哎你好车只能到这了
Others: Hey, hello, the car can only go this far.
Lucia:  哈
Lucia: Ha!
Jake: 失败大失败
Jake: Failure, big failure.
Katrina: 我来拿这个吧
Katrina: I'll take this.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Shure:  那要要不你护蛋吧
Shure: Then how about you protect the egg?
Alice:护蛋
Alice: Protect the egg?
Shure:  蛋对
Shure: Yes, the egg.
其他人：人多力量大一人一个就完了
Others: Strength in numbers, everyone takes one.
Alice:护蛋笑死
Alice: Protect the egg, so funny.
Jake: 对分不到都
Jake: Yeah, everyone gets one.
Alice:护蛋使者是吗
Alice: Protector of the egg, huh?
Lucia:  你这个任务艰巨
Lucia: Your task is a tough one.
Lucia:  一定要保护好他哈哈
Lucia: Make sure you protect it well, haha.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:谁把我的蛋撞碎了我就把谁撞死
Alice: If anyone breaks my egg, I'll break them.
Lucia:  哈哈哈好可怕
Lucia: Haha, that's scary.
Alice:确实我们疯P是这样的
Alice: Seriously, our team is like that.
Shure:  我们回去又可以坐保姆车了
Shure: We can take the nanny van back.
Lucia:  每天被撞的现代人
Lucia: Modern people get hit every day.
Alice:精神状态良好
Alice: Mental state is good.
Katrina:  现几点钟
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure:  5点多回去
Shure: After 5, we'll head back.
Katrina:  还写毕设
Katrina: Still have to write the thesis.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哎你别说了
Katrina: Hahaha, hey, don't mention it.
Shure:  我也工作一会
Shure: I have to work a bit too.
Shure:  不然话leader该发飙了
Shure: Or the leader will flip out.
Shure:  妈的你小子提了5天线上
Shure: Damn, you promised five days online.
Katrina:  我也是
Katrina: Me too.
Shure:  然后一点活不干哈哈哈
Shure: And then you do nothing at all, haha.
Katrina:  咱这是还要上去吧我记得
Katrina: We still have to go up, right, I remember.
Lucia:  对对就是为了融入人类社会
Lucia: Right, right, just to blend into human society.
Lucia:  我不得不把自己伪装的像人类一样
Lucia: I have to disguise myself like a human.
Katrina:  还要上去一层是不是
Katrina: We have to go up one more floor, right?
Shure: 上去才对
Shure: Going up is correct.
Lucia:  哈哈哈微微露出一个轻蔑的笑容
Lucia: Haha, slightly showing a contemptuous smile.
Tasha:  哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina:  转转
Katrina: Spin around
Katrina:  杨导说他21号没空
Katrina: Director Yang said he's not available on the 21st.
Katrina:  然后你跟他对接一下时间吧
Katrina: So you should coordinate with him for another time.
Shure:  你干嘛呢下午
Shure: What are you doing this afternoon?
Shure:  们6个人正好打一个商务
Shure: There are six of us, perfect for a business game.
Jake: 对打个商务好
Jake: Yeah, a business game sounds good.
Jake: 就在这等着吧
Jake: Let's wait here then.
Jake: 哎这边我看一下在哪打车哈
Jake: Hey, let me check where we can get a cab from here.
Jake: 在这在喜茶那合个影吧要不
Jake: How about we take a picture over there by Heytea?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake: 就是或者就在这个地方也很
Jake: Or maybe just right here, it's also very...
Jake: 我先打车
Jake: I'll hail a cab first.
Shure:  没开吧那个
Shure: It's not open, right?
Shure:  然后谢斌竹随便给我拿点衣服
Shure: Then Xie Bin just randomly grabbed some clothes for me.
Shure:  我收拾行李让他给我收拾
Shure: I was packing my luggage and he helped me out.
Shure:  他给我拿了4件外套一个t恤
Shure: He got me four jackets and a t-shirt.
Katrina:  神经
Katrina: Crazy
Jake: 还有11分钟才到
Jake: It'll take another 11 minutes to arrive.
Jake: 所以放地上吧
Jake: So just put it on the ground.
Shure:  先放一会吧
Shure: Let's just leave it here for now.
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Yeah, just leave it here.
Lucia:  好好吧
Lucia: Alright, fine.
Lucia:  你对生活的热爱
Lucia: Your love for life...
Lucia:  sorry看错了
Lucia: Sorry, I misread it.
Jake: 这样可以拍吧
Jake: Can we take pictures like this?
Jake: 这样可以拍吗
Lucia:  你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: You're awake, hahaha, that's brilliant.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahahaha
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Jake: 好就这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's leave it at that.
Shure:  来我们叫醒一下AI
Shure: Let's wake up the AI.
Jake: 就这样挺好
Jake: It's fine like this.
Jake: 来来来叫醒叫醒一下
Jake: Come on, let's wake it up.
Jake: 叫醒服务
Jake: Wake-up service.
Katrina:  到底谁啊
Katrina: Who is it exactly?
Lucia:  呃他的手机
Lucia: Uh, his phone.
Shure:  咱们一个一个露出来吧
Shure: Let's reveal them one by one.
Shure:  咱们先拍一张
Shure: Let's take a photo first.
Shure:  然后拍个视频
Shure: Then we can shoot a video.
Katrina:  1234还差一个人呢
Katrina: We're still one person short with 1234.
Lucia:  呃薇薇
Lucia: Uh, Tasha.
Lucia:  要合个影
Lucia: We need to take a group photo.
Katrina: 站起来 突然晕了
Katrina: Standing up, I suddenly feel dizzy.
Katrina:  气血不足是这样的
Katrina: It's from lack of blood flow.
Shure:  喝牛奶喝的
Shure: It's from drinking milk.
Katrina:  喝牛奶喝的一碗一喝的
Katrina: Yeah, drinking a bowl of milk.
Shure:  有一人没露出来快快快
Shure: Someone's not in the frame, hurry up.
Jake: 快快快
Jake: Hurry up.
Jake: 晚了再来一次
Jake: Too late, let's do it again.
Alice:还没带眼镜呢
Alice: I haven't put on my glasses yet.
Shure:  而且你没戴眼镜
Shure: And you're not wearing your glasses.
Alice:来了
Alice: Here I come.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Shure:  那已经是2077年了
Shure: It's already the year 2077.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 等会我把这个带上忘了
Jake: Wait, I forgot to put this on.
Shure:  Wifi没带上
Shure: Didn't bring the wifi.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没
Jake: Hahahahahaha, nope.
Shure:  哈哈哈接收不着信号了
Shure: Hahaha, can't get any signal.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  好心急还补一下
Shure: So eager, need to fix it.
Lucia:  马上收不到信号了
Lucia: We'll lose signal soon.
Shure:  是吗让自己看的像个活人一样
Shure: Really, make yourself look alive.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:怎么按反了呢啊
Alice: Why did it press the opposite way?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 呃没关系歪对啊
Jake: Uh, it's okay, it's crooked, yeah.
Alice:有点歪说实话
Alice: It's a bit crooked, to be honest.
Shure:  不是可以拍这个转场
Shure: It's okay, we can shoot the transition.
Lucia:  哈哈搅动转场
Lucia: Haha, stirring the transition.
Jake: 好再来
Jake: Alright, again.
Tasha: 怎么这么暗
Tasha: Why is it so dark?
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  非常帅
Shure: Very handsome.
Jake: 这次很好
Jake: This time is great.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Jake: 那视频一个一个出
Jake: We'll release the videos one by one.
Shure:  啊视频好
Shure: Ah, the videos are good.
Jake: 一个一个进来
Jake: Bring them in one by one.
Jake: 然后你醒了
Jake: Then you wake up.
Jake: 你醒了你醒了
Jake: You wake up, you wake up.
Katrina:  要说这句话是吗
Katrina: I need to say this line, right?
Jake: 呵要吗
Jake: Haha, do you need to?
Jake: 可以要
Jake: You could.
Shure:  好快快先撤出来
Shure: Okay, let's quickly withdraw.
Alice:来呀谁呀
Alice: Come on, who is it?
Shure:  从杨老板开始
Shure: Start with Jake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You wake up.
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You wake up.
Shure:  进来
Shure: Come in.
Shure:  你就不知道走了
Shure: You just don't know how to leave.
Jake: 进来就呆着
Jake: Come in and just stay.
Jake: 重来重来重来
Jake: Again, again, again.
Shure:  哎重来没有默契没有啊
Shure: Ah, no coordination, no!
Tasha:  什么你醒了
Tasha: What, you wake up?
Alice:你醒了
Alice: You wake up.
Jake: 来来来闪开
Jake: Come on, move aside.
Lucia:  那个表情包
Lucia: That meme.
Tasha:  哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Lucia:  你醒了快起来做作业哈哈
Lucia: You wake up, hurry up and do your homework, haha.
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You wake up.
Alice:醒了
Alice: Woke up.
Lucia:  你醒了
Lucia: You wake up.
Tasha:  醒了
Tasha: Woke up.
Katrina:  你醒了
Katrina: You wake up.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You wake up.
Katrina:  你醒了
Katrina: You wake up.
Shure:  你醒了吗
Shure: Are you awake?
Jake: 2077啊哈哈哈哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: 2077, haha, you fool.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈我靠哈
Tasha: Hahaha, oh my god, haha.
Katrina:  这是噩梦你知道吗这噩
Katrina: This is a nightmare, you know, this night...
Tasha:  哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Lucia:  哈哈瞬间变恐怖片
Lucia: Haha, it instantly turned into a horror movie.
Jake: 我靠很难
Jake: Oh man, it's really tough.
Jake: 哈哈哈直接晕倒
Jake: Haha, just faint straight away.
Alice:你不要过来呀
Alice: Don't come over here!
Lucia:  你不要过来呀你不要过来
Lucia: Don't come over here, don't come over!
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈根本醒不了
Jake: Haha, you can't wake up at all.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  直接鬼压床了
Shure: It's like sleep paralysis.
Jake: ha ha
Jake: Ha ha.
Jake: 看一眼车
Jake: Take a look at the car.
Jake: 还有8分钟
Jake: There's 8 minutes left.
Jake: 还能再整点活
Jake: We can still do a bit more.
Lucia:  想看一眼那个视频
Lucia: I want to take a look at that video.
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 好慢啊
Jake: So slow.
Lucia:  新物种生活
Lucia: New species life.
Jake: 傻吊
Jake: Idiot.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:有鬼
Alice: There's a ghost.
Katrina:  太恐怖了这
Katrina: This is so scary.
Jake: 新物种生活确实
Jake: New species life indeed.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Alice:有脏东西哈哈
Alice: There's something dirty, haha.
Shure:  我靠新物种生活
Shure: Oh man, new species life.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  上面这字还很应景
Shure: The words on top are so fitting.
Jake: 可以这个
Jake: This is good.
Jake: 最后一天的开场视频都有了
Jake: We've got the opening video for the last day.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  对噔噔噔
Shure: Yeah, duh duh duh.
Shure:  你醒吧然后就大家就都退出去了
Shure: You wake up, and then everyone just leaves.
Shure:  我那个叫什么10秒点出率
Shure: What's it called, 10-second click-through rate?
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, hahaha.
Shure:  就卡在我那10秒了
Shure: It just got stuck at my 10 seconds.
Jake: 丰收歌曲
Jake: Harvest song
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay
Tasha:  是星期日还是星期一呀
Tasha: Is it Sunday or Monday?
Jake: 星期日
Jake: Sunday
Tasha:  星期日
Tasha: Sunday
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Alice:快递快递
Alice: Delivery, delivery
Alice:你必须给我快点
Alice: You have to hurry up for me
Shure: （歌词）自由经过了山
Shure: (lyrics) Freedom passed through the mountains
Shure:  （歌词）我想开着我的烂摩托转一转
Shure: (lyrics) I want to ride my old motorbike around
Shure:  （歌词）可惜我的心
Shure: (lyrics) But unfortunately, my heart
Shure:  （歌词）我可惜我把车卖了
Shure: (lyrics) Unfortunately, I sold my bike
Shure:  （歌词）我的心呀我的心
Shure: (lyrics) My heart, my heart
Shure:  （歌词）变成了处处处处都给你
Shure: (lyrics) Has turned into giving everything to you
Alice:还有大概半个小时能录
Alice: We can record for about another half hour
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem
Jake: 就上车就关掉
Jake: Just get on the car and turn it off
Lucia:  当前网络不稳定
Lucia: The current network is unstable
Shure:  （歌词）躲在屋檐的
Shure: (lyrics) Hiding under the eaves
Shure:  刷哈哈哈
Shure: Ha ha ha
Shure:  啊你在拍照啊
Shure: Ah, you’re taking pictures
Jake: 等会等会等会你你你
Jake: Wait, wait, wait, you, you, you
Shure:  你浪费我的表情了
Shure: You wasted my expression
Jake: 你从后面绕过来吧
Jake: Come around from the back
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Jake: 我开始我开始录了
Jake: I’ve started recording
Jake: 哼沙雕
Jake: Hum, idiot
Jake: 靠是
Jake: Damn, it's fine
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Shure:  到了吗车看眼
Shure: Are we there yet? Look at the car
Shure:  车看眼车
Shure: Look at the car, the car
Jake: 还有5分钟
Jake: Another 5 minutes
Jake: 出去等着吧
Jake: Go wait outside
Jake: 走吧出去吧
Jake: Let's go, go outside
Shure:  （歌词）起来饥寒交迫的人
Shure: (lyrics) Stand up, all who suffer from hunger and cold
Shure:  蛋护好蛋
Shure: Protect the egg, protect the egg
Jake: 蛋在哪啊
Jake: Where's the egg?
Lucia:  把我吓得又倒头就睡真的
Lucia: It scared me so much that I went back to sleep, really
Jake: 走上道路口
Jake: Walk up to the intersection
Jake: 这过得去吧
Jake: This should be fine, right?
Tasha:  那当然是翻山越岭
Tasha: Well, of course, it's climbing over mountains.
Shure:  他到哪了
Shure: Where is he now?
Shure:  我看一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
Jake: 三分钟
Jake: Three minutes.
Shure:  就在咱们面前是吧
Shure: Right in front of us, right?
Shure:  那咱们从那绕一下吧走吧
Shure: Let's go around that way.
Jake: 啊他
Jake: Oh, he...
Jake: 他说可以开进来
Jake: He said he could drive in.
Shure:  不这是非机动车道
Shure: No, this is a non-motorized lane.
Shure:  他进不来的
Shure: He can't come in.
Tasha:  他可以看到外面那个吧
Tasha: He can see the outside, right?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 走试试
Jake: Let's try it.
Jake: 那要不怎么照
Jake: How else can we take a picture?
Tasha:  哎你小心摄像头
Tasha: Hey, watch out for the camera.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Tasha:  我是说钻的时候
Tasha: I mean while you're squeezing through.
Shure:  钻的是吧
Shure: Squeezing through, right?
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, got it.
Shure:  要钻过去是吧
Shure: We need to squeeze through, right?
Jake: 哎从旁边不能过吗
Jake: Hey, can't we go from the side?
Shure:  旁边
Shure: The side?
Tasha:  可以呀
Tasha: Yeah, we can.
Shure:  真费劲吧
Shure: That's a hassle, right?
Shure:  杨老板你你你你能吗
Shure: Jake, can you do it?
Katrina:  当心车当心车
Katrina: Watch out for the car, watch out for the car.
Shure:  337是吗
Shure: 337, right?
Shure:  那辆不是保姆车
Shure: That's not the nanny car.
Shure:  疑似
Shure: Suspected.
Shure:  776 对没错
Shure: 776, yes, correct.
Tasha:  这是棕色吗
Tasha: Is this brown?
Katrina:  要放后备箱吗
Katrina: Do we need to put it in the trunk?
Shure:  哪有后备箱姐
Shure: Where's the trunk, sis?
Katrina:  哦哦哦对不起哈哈哈我给忘了
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, sorry, haha, I forgot.
Shure:  啊尾号7008是吧
Shure: Ah, the last digits are 7008, right?
Jake: 对对可对了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Shure:  啊 7008
Shure: Ah, 7008.
Shure:  不是哪有后备箱啊你想想
Shure: No, where's the trunk, think about it.
Lucia:  啊没有啊没有
Lucia: Ah, there's no trunk.
其他人：不是你要有箱子啊
Others: No, you need to have a box.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
其他人：那赶紧上啊赶紧上啊
Others: Hurry up, hurry up!
Shure:  这这些上来就行
Shure: These can just go up.
Alice:蛋啊你可别碎啊
Alice: Egg, please don't break.
其他人：滴滴专车为您服务请您系好安全带
Others: Didi Car Service at your service, please fasten your seatbelt.
Shure:  我要做来的老板呗
Shure: I want to be the boss.
Jake: 呀再次保安位
Jake: Yeah, security again.
Alice:蛋没事吧
Alice: Is the egg okay?
Jake: 关吧
Jake: Close it.
Tasha:  没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia:  理论上说是不是我理财
Lucia: Theoretically, isn't it my investment?
Alice:停吧
Alice: Stop it.
Lucia:  应该是保安
Lucia: It should be security.
Lucia:  然后我下去刚好给你们一开门
Lucia: Then I'll go down and open the door for you.
Alice:这个可以停了吗
Alice: Can we stop this now?
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure:  没有把它录了放冰箱里吧
Shure: No, just record it and put it in the fridge.
Jake: 下车开始录
Jake: Start recording when you get off the car.
Jake: 我录完放冰箱
Jake: I'll finish recording and put it in the fridge.
Jake: 放到冰箱就给我导
Jake: After putting it in the fridge, give it to me.
Lucia:  哎所以现在要暂停吗
Lucia: So, should we pause now?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  要暂停吗
Shure: Should we pause?